hey guys what's up it's Tom Molyneux I
am the ace Seattle Comicon having a
great time meaning everyone it's going
really well I wanted to apologize
because there's no real revelations
coming out this weekend about spider-man
- I don't know much about it I'm a
little confused because I died so I
don't really know how it all comes into
play but I do know is I've got the new
script I'm super excited to read it and
it's gonna be great so yeah spider-man
soon let's do this
hey everybody its charlie how do you
like Tom Holland now he's having a
comic-con panel this weekend so he did
this video too sly dropped the title for
spider-man homecoming 2 which we now can
say is officially just called spider-man
far from home which is actually a pretty
good title loaded with meaning of course
so let's all break it down we got
details on the villain in what's going
on with the global storyline that
they're telling very different from the
first spider-man homecoming movie much
much bigger story there is a new round
of that infinity war blu-ray giveaway
going on all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this totally was
not expecting this tonight because Tom
Hahn
usually drops really cool stuff during
his comic-con panels which is actually
happening later tonight so I wouldn't be
surprised if this was just the beginning
because there's still all this Avengers
for stuff that we have to figure out he
even acknowledges it during this little
video like oh you know I'm supposed to
be dead even though we're ramping up to
shoot spider-man 2 the funny thing about
the title is is it actually as the same
name is the title of a 1989 drew
Barrymore film that represented her
first on-screen kiss so this is youth
aspect to it but I don't think that
they're too inspired by this classic
film far from home means literally far
from home because he's gonna be
traveling all over the world they're
filming it locations all over the world
actually practically shooting the movie
most of it's happening in London they
shot the last spider-man movie mostly in
Atlanta Marvel usually shoots its films
in Atlanta nowadays unless they have
some special stuff that they need to
film like when they were filming the
Scotland scenes for infinity war for
Scarlet Witch envision and all that
Secret Avengers stuff I've already done
a couple videos about the main villain
Mysterio the vulture was announced as
coming back Michael Keaton will be in
the sequel they didn't say
much but obviously they're building
towards sinister six so it makes sense
that they would try to bring him back
especially with that scorpion
post-credits tag at the end of the last
movie this is that on you it's on our
little spider friend I've got some boys
on the outside who'd love to meet him
you know take a picture slice his throat
but his head in a dryer and I heard a
rumor no but right now we know that it's
gonna be Quentin Beck Mysterio the
special effects wizard that then turns
to crime Jake Gyllenhaal was the person
that was supposedly going to be cast as
the character and I think that'd be
fantastic casting but Marvel hasn't
announced him specifically and that's
probably just because they're waiting to
get that contract sign but it was the
same thing with Benedict Cumberbatch at
Comic Con a couple years ago like they
can't say that the actor is playing the
role until everybody has signed every
piece of paper necessary
in getting into the Avengers for
timeline of it all if you haven't seen
any of the Avengers for spider-man
specific videos that I've done what's
happening is is Avengers four ends
minutes later spider-man 2 picks up far
from home as we call it now the other
big question now is is after Avengers 4
which of those Avengers that come back
from the ashes will cross over into his
film part of the original Sony sharing
arrangement with spider-man is is that
Marvel gave them access to a list
Avengers so you're talking core Avengers
popping up in spider-man movies last
time it was a Robert Downey jr. but
because iron man's status is pending in
two phase four like what's gonna be the
future of the character will they
survive will he be a digital AI is he
gonna be the one to wield the Infinity
Gauntlet or will he be sacrificed so
that someone can wield the gauntlet
right now Captain America is higher on
my list for people that will sacrifice
themselves give up their life so that
someone can wield the gauntlet because
of that soul gem twist so Ironman still
could totally wind up dying but he's not
quite as high on the list as Captain
America because of the way Chris Evans
feels about doing Marvel movies in
general like he really likes being in
Marvel movies but of the two Robert
Downey jr. is just way more jazzed up
about being Iron Man I think Chris Evans
is about being Captain America and all
these movies nothing they can't do men
and such and I'm sure it's gonna have
the exact same effect when Captain
Marvel comes out and then the Black
Widow movie comes out Marvel just has
the winning recipe and and they're
they're kind of one step ahead of
everybody else and I mean just looking
at them it was just looking at things
this morning about the Black Panther the
the openings around the country this
weekend Scott so Kevin Feige already
confirmed that going through phase four
phase five in the future Captain Marvel
is gonna be the new face of the MCU
meaning that whether he lives or dies
Iron Man is transitioning to a more
background role which just lends more
credence to the idea that they're gonna
go with the comic book twist and he'll
be more of an AI that just speaks to
Peter but he might actually be dead and
have just uploaded his consciousness to
AI via sureties technology the really
cool thing about Sheree with vision now
as you wonder if she's so good at
deconstructing people's minds like
Winter Soldier she has deep scans of the
mind gem she helped vision out even
though they had to cut that short
couldn't she do that with a human now
would she have a way to easily duplicate
someone's consciousness so that's a way
for Marvel to continue using Robert
Downey jr. indefinitely without
requiring him to be on screen all the
time there was a video that I did a
little while ago about spider-man in the
next movie - the costume designer
confirmed that he was going to be
getting some costume changes mostly
because he's becoming a spider-man like
going from being a boy to being a man
because he's about 16 17 when infinity
war picks up he'll be another year older
and have gone through all this crap with
the snap sure what's going on this
summer is is they're gonna start
shooting the movie spider-man 2 in July
so that means that they'll be shooting
while comic-con is going on
there's no Marvel Hall H panel Sony is
bringing venom they haven't said
anything about Tom Holland maybe he'll
film a special message to thank the fans
and do some accidental spoiler again
from the set but just to be clear him
revealing the title here this is not him
accidentally spoiling it this was
definitely planned that's not the script
on his iPad there that's probably just a
picture with the title on it just to let
people know like they probably wanted
him to reveal the title so just remember
Marvel understands the Tom Holland is
not good with withholding information he
just can't keep secrets so they're gonna
lean into this and just have fun with it
and use it to reveal information about
the movie as they want to here's a
really funny montage of other actors
trying to stop him from spoiling the
plot of all these movies
whenever Chris Pratt I'd Dave position
now you understand why they paired him
with Benedict Cumberbatch for all that
infinity war press that was genuine that
wasn't them playing around that was him
really almost accidentally giving away
information in Benedict Cumberbatch the
pro who's done this for a long long time
just blocking for him like no kid nope
just be quiet just stop talking right
now there's a comic-con panel happening
tonight if they reveal any cool Avengers
for information or more info about
spider-man 2 I will totally do a video
about it but leave all your requests in
the comments below
congratulations to Casey you're the
latest giveaway winner please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for that brand new
ant-man and the wasp Avengers 4 trailer
and click here to learn more about
Mysterio in spider-man 2 thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]